- Bam!
(epic music plays)
(speaks foreign language)
(inaudible whining)
- [Brunette Girl] This is crazy!
- I don't understand anything!
- I can't believe she's Asian.
(laughter)
(classical violin music)
- We're playing mahjong
(speaks foreign language)
That means "play mahjong."
So mahjong is a really old
game that originated in China.
It's one of the best games
that I've ever played.
- It looks like chess and
checkers and cards combined.
- I've never even seen it played
but I know it's supposed to be really fun
and there's a lot of yelling involved.
- If you're losing, yes.
- I really don't know what this game is.
I've only seen it played
in Chinese dramas.
- The best way to start learning is
to understand what the tiles are.
You have three types of tiles.
You have suits, honors, and bonus, okay?
So usually we play on a square table
because it's just easier.
So now we're going to wash them
and everyone turn them
over onto their green.
So wash them.
Like, rotate it.
Oh sh-t.
The grandmas, the aunts,
everyone will play
this around the table.
The kids will hang out
and they would just gossip over stuff.
Yeah, it was part of growing up.
There was like, five sets of
mahjong in my grandma's house
and she invited every human over to play.
Everyone has a version of mahjong.
This is gonna be pretty
basic like, Chinese version.
- It's just pretty much
like a matching game almost.
- It is a matching game.
- Is it like that one game Bullsh-t?
- [Brunette] So I take two, you take two.
You take two.
- [Guy With The Glasses] Okay.
- You take two.
- [Blonde Girl] It has to be the next one?
- [Brunette Girl] Yep.
Faster guys, quick status, yep.
Everyone's fast in this game.
- [Guy With The Hat] Got it, got it.
- Okay, so you can either choose
- (inaudible)
- [Brunette Girl] That's a dragon.
- [Guy With A Hat] Girl!
What are you doin'?
- What do I do now?
- Nothing! Now he goes.
- [Guy With A Hat] Two of a kind is good.
(laughter)
(inaudible muttering)
- Ha! Bam!
- [Brunette Girl] He's crazy!
- [Guy With A Hat] I feel
like I'm getting in touch
with my Asian heritage
and I am winning at it.
Yes!
- So Mallory, when did you start playing?
- I learned probably early on, like seven.
My grandma and my mom would talk about it
and say "this is this" and "that's that"
you have to match them and
it's like a matching game.
But I never played probably
until I was in college.
- How come?
- My grandma died so then
mahjong kind of left with her.
- Wait! Wait wait wait! Did I win?
- Do you have pairs? And a--
(tiles clatter)
- No!
- Hide that two four!
It has to be Pong, Kong,
or Chow and then one pair.
Also, you should say "mahjong."
- Mahjong! Why?
- It's like Uno.
So basically you have
one last hand to play.
F-ck.
- Yeah. Suck it.
Wait wait. I might have three.
- You know what they say?
- Three right?
- Mahjong. Oh sh-t.
- Ah! You have mahjong?
Wait, does that mean you won?
- [Brunette Girl] Yeah
(cries of protest)
- Okay this game is rigged.
(peppy piano music)
- So fun 'cause I almost won.
- Not gonna lie it was
hard but it was fun, yeah.
How can you say that you did a bad job
when you get three white dragons?
- [Guy With A Hat] I
definitely feel more connected
with my Chinese side
'cause I remember learning
these Chinese characters
when I was in school
and it totally reminded me of that stuff.
- I had a great time.
I would love to invite
friends over, gossip, play it.
- [Guy With Hat] Yeah, that sounds fun.
- [Guy With Glasses] Let's just
all hang out and play this.
- [Blonde Girl] Yeah, I'm down.
- If there's alcohol, I'll be there.
You gave me the easy ones?
These Asians?